what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some really exciting news
today news that I bet a lot of people
thought was never actually going to
happen and even now might possibly have
their doubts which I totally understand
because it seems like we are getting a
Mephisto Disney plus special not series
but special and I know right now
everybody is getting flashbacks to One
Division where we thought Mephisto was
going to be the main villain we thought
it was going to pop up in each episode
but he never did well now it looks like
it's actually happening and it could
possibly be happening this year so not
too far away we'll talk about that but
also the test screenings for Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 3. it seems Marvel
Studios has had a test screening
recently and thanks to some Insider
knowledge we seem to know how some of
the people who saw it felt about the
film so of course we have to talk about
that and if you're new and you love
Marvel be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest Marvel
Cinematic Universe News so right away no
this is not a meme although I don't
think we'll ever get past the Mephisto
memes but Mephisto has been rumored to
actually be coming to the MCU soon he is
reportedly supposed to play a key role
in The Iron Heart series a series that
has been described as mixing science and
engineering with magic the Marvel
character the hood is confirmed to be
the villain of the show or at least one
of them and in the comics the hood is
part demon and he does have some magical
abilities right now as rumor has it the
Fisto is responsible for him getting his
powers and Mephisto is reportedly either
going to be mentioned severely hinted at
or might actually appear in this show
and the biggest report that we've gotten
so far is that the actor who played
Borat Sasha Baron Cohen will be playing
the demon Devil Himself Mephisto and
this all seems to line up it seemingly
makes sense but so did a lot of theories
about one division however keep in mind
and this is very important the report
about out Sasha Baron Cohen playing
Mephisto came from deadline a very
reputable and trustworthy website so on
top of this we have a report today
stating that Mephisto is getting his own
Disney plus special presentation
industry Insider Jeff Snyder has
recently claimed on the hot Mike podcast
that Marvel Studios right now is doing a
special presentation centered around
Mephisto and to quote him it's shooting
right now and what's really interesting
is that he says it's shooting on the set
of Agatha coven of chaos and that
Mephisto might actually be the villain
of Agatha coven of chaos which does make
sense and I gotta say if we are truly
going to a darker magical side of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe this is
awesome we have Agatha who uses dark
magic and then we'll get the demon
himself Mephisto now when can we expect
this to come well it looks like this
could be Marvel Studios Halloween
special this year in 2022 Marvel kind of
went a little bit darker with Multiverse
of Madness and then with the Halloween
special werewolf by Knight and that was
also a special presentation which was
done I think incredibly well but it also
did take us to that darker side and it
looks like Marvel is planning on
continuing to do that which is great
because as we've recently talked about I
think doing too many Disney Plus shows
could be problematic especially if
Marvel Studios is trying to focus on
quality over quantity however Disney
plus specials that could be anywhere
from 45 minutes to an hour and a half
long could be executed really really
well especially if they are doing what
they're doing right now and that is
filming Agatha coven of chaos but also
filming the Mephisto special at the same
time that is incredibly smart it's very
efficient and you can still have that
quality in fact Marvel Studios recently
did that for Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 and the Guardians of the Galaxy
Christmas special and I personally and
saw that many many fans really loved the
holiday special and speaking of it
sounds like Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 is testing pretty well now this
doesn't really come as that big of a
surprise James Gunn has done an
incredible job with the Guardians
franchise so far a great job with
guardians of galaxy vol 1 volume 2 and
then again as we just mentioned with the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
so despite what you might think about
his choices for the upcoming DC slate he
has done a great job with the Guardians
franchise so it would be kind of weird
if Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 his
farewell to the franchise that he loves
is bad but it doesn't seem like we
really have to worry about that on that
same episode of the hot mic podcast
Insider Jeff Snyder said that he has
heard Loki season 2 is great and that
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is great
and also in replies to this report The
Insider Casey Walsh also said yes about
Guardians of the Galaxy but you never
put a ton of stock and opinions via Tess
basically stating yes he has heard that
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is great
as well however things can change with
pest screenings and we've also learned
recently since Marvel revealed this to
us that their test screenings are
basically with their employees and
sometimes they have no idea what they're
about to watch they don't tell them hey
this is going to be a test screening for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 but hey
here's an invite for a test screening
then they show up and they watch
Guardians volume 3. so some of the
people who watch it might not be the
biggest Marvel fans because remember
it's Disney employees but based off of
the report from Jeff Snyder it sounds
like the reviews are pretty good so far
and I really love that he also said that
Loki season 2 is great as well because
this is one of the most anticipated
Disney Plus shows that is coming up that
is coming out this year well at least we
hope so fingers crossed on that there is
definitely a big and heavy importance
placed on season 2 of Loki season 1
basically started off phase four with
our villain King the Conqueror slash he
who remains Loki truly Dove us into the
Multiverse showing us what different
variants could be like showing us what
different timelines could be like then
in the finale they introduced us to he
who remains a variant of Kang and showed
us just how dangerous he could be and
what is coming now in the Multiverse
Saga and if you've seen that
post-credits scene for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania you know that Loki
season 2 looks pretty dang good and that
Loki is pretty dang scared which of
course he should be because Kang is
going to be an absolute Beast of a big
bad and who knows where else he might
show up in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now with Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
we're not expecting any type of Kang
Cameo it is definitely possible but
since this is the final movie of the
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise at
least with this current team and with
James Gunn we're assuming that the focus
is going to be kept on our team and Adam
Warlock and of course the high
evolutionary however a post-credit scene
could definitely tease Kang the big bad
and a lot of fans really really loved
Kang in Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
even if they didn't actually like the
movie itself but with these reports
stating that Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 is testing really greatly right now
that's great news to MCU fans because
that's the next movie that we're going
to see and it sounds like James Gunn is
going to deliver as always so be sure to
let us know all of your thoughts about
all of this recent news it does look
like Mephisto was coming to the MCU
maybe at some point in time he won't be
a meme although I can definitely see the
Borat Mephisto meme starting to happen
when he does enter the MCU kind of
hoping that happens but the dark magical
side of the MCU does seem to be right
around the corner and of course also let
us know how excited you are about
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and Loki
season 2 which we should be getting this
year as well fingers crossed so let us
know your thoughts down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest MCU news of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof